illegal border crossings hitting another
all-time high surpassing 300,000 in
December alone now former FBI officials
are surround sounding the alarm on a new
national security threat as 50 on the
terror watch list were already caught
this fiscal year in a letter to Congress
those officials warning quote the United
States is facing a new and imminent
danger adding in its modern history the
US has never suffered an invasion of the
Homeland and yet one is unfolding now
here to react National Patrol president
Brandon Jud Brandon great to see you I
got to tell you when I saw this letter I
my I was shocked not at the
acknowledgement not at the reality but
at the acknowledgment of the reality I I
was I I know the numbers of the
terrorist watch list I know what's going
on but I guess I was surprised that
former FBI officials would be willing to
put this out like this cuz it was more
than a warning I feel like it was an
indictment of this
Administration yeah it's it's not an if
it's a win we know something bad is
going to happen and you have to look at
the reason why uh when you look at the
the number of people that we apprehended
302,000 people that means we released a
minimum of 280,000 of those individuals
we only held into custody about 20,000
for for repatriation so when you look at
that when you look at the the sheer Mass
Crush of people that are crossing our
borders illegally what that means is we
just don't have um agents in the field
to patrol the Border that's when the
cartels can cross their High higher
value products including people from
countries that want to do us hard harm
everybody wants to characterize this as
a race issue they want to say well this
is just poor brown people coming from
Mexico or Central America and that's
just not true we apprehend people from
Eastern um Europe all the time we
apprehend people that are whiter than I
am all the time we apprehend people from
from the Middle East we apprehend people
from around the the world this is not a
race issue it's all about the protection
of the American people and until we wake
up and realize that we're going to
continue to deal with this and and
what's going to happen is going to be
bigger than what it needs to be we've
got to get this under control um today
and we can do it if this Administration
would simply give us the policies that
are necessary to your point Brandon I
think people still have this conception
in their head that illegal immigration
is the guy that wants to come over here
and does low skilled low labor jobs and
is striving for a better life and that
may be a percentage of the people coming
over here but I I put this FBI letter
out for example in my social media and
somebody said oh yeah all these Mexican
guys want to come over here and bomb
things they don't it's I don't think
people understand the extent of people
coming from places like you just
described who come at a minimum from
countries with ill int where there's an
ideology of ill intention but at a
maximum are on the literal Terror watch
list yeah and and the reason is is
because the woke media refuses is to
give an honest conversation to the
American people so if you watch CNN
MSNBC um ABC you all of those CBS if you
watch those news outlets they're
constantly covering for this
Administration they will not tell the
American people exactly what's going on
if we had that honest conversation if
people understood what was going on they
would be up in arms they would be
extremely frustrated but what's great
about it is all of these images that
you're showing every single time
something happens here in the United
States people have to wake up and what's
really funny about that is Eric Adams
has unwittingly become the face of
border security CU every single time he
talks this powerful Democrat every
single time he opens his mouth then the
mainstream media has to cover it and
then people tune in to Fox News thank
goodness and that's why President
Biden's poll numbers are so low on
illegal immigration but it's only
recently that those numbers have dropped
to to to lows that we've never never
thought that would have ever happened
yeah well Brandon thanks for being with
us hopefully we can break through that
that false narrative about the problem
that exists always great to see you
thanks
Brandon thank you will appreciate it I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian killme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis